[Music]
there's always drama to tune into on the
small screen but these TV shows have had
plenty go down behind the scenes to et
is breaking down TVs biggest scandals of
2018 I was always pretty political the
highly rated Roseanne reboot was
abruptly canceled by ABC after its star
Roseanne Barr posted a racially charged
political tweet she later deleted and
apologized for the post but the damage
was done how does it feel to be back in
the spotlight Arrested Development
season 5 came under fire when during a
recent New York Times interview actress
Jessica Walter accused co-star Jeffrey
Tambor of verbal harassment during their
time working together the allegation
came just months after Tambor exited his
Amazon studio series transparent
following sexual misconduct accusations
which he has denied everybody's a little
shell-shocked well let's hope because I
love this show and I would like to find
a way for it to continue because it's an
important show for television yes we we
all would most assuredly okay house of
cards is returning for season six this
time with Robin Wright in command after
former lead Kevin Spacey was accused of
sexual assault and misconduct by several
men Netflix announced they no longer
wanted to be involved in any further
production of the show that included
Spacey
through his lawyer Spacey has denied all
allegations Danny Masterson will no
longer be a part of the ranch on Netflix
after sexual assault allegations
stemming from the early 2000s resurfaced
allegations which Masterson
denied and denounced as without merit
regardless his character was written off
the show he was noticeably absent from
the new season trailer even though he
will appear in limited episodes
you